good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how to choose the
right career you have to love what you
do and I'm not going to go over that
long but it solves a lot of problems
because when you love what you do would
you really love what you do you work
harder I mean I have friends that don't
love and you know I tell this story a
wall street-type big guy but I was
richer than him and I'm richer according
to Forbes of much richer than him so I
like that you know I like that but
there's big Wall Street Titan he's a big
name he has a son and his son is a
wonderful human being which is amazing
because the guy's a horrible a horrible
person but he's one of the biggest guys
on Wall Street so he wants his son Alex
I'm gonna use the name Alex it's not his
name but I don't want to get this guy in
any more trouble with his father the new
already it's Alex isn't the strongest
character the father is a brutal vicious
killer so the father has a big firm on
Wall Street and he wants Alex to go into
the firm of course you know come on Alex
get in there get in there in the
meantime all these kids are graduating
from Wharton and Harvard and Stanford
and they're just eating Alex's lunch he
doesn't have a chance he does have a
chance and he doesn't like it he's not
liking what he's doing you got to love
what you do
he's not like him so one day but he
can't leave because there's father I
actually told why don't you leave your
father's brutal the father's just
killing the guys tell him you don't have
what it takes I'm sorry dad oh this is
great so I say you got to leave the
father you got to leave him he said I
just can't Donald Sonja he's a spoiled
guy he's a member of a very good golf
club in Westchester which is a rich
place in New York and he's on one of the
committees and he's on the greens
committee and they put him in charge of
redoing the course they're doing this
big renovation of the course it's a very
good club and he's there every morning
at 5:00 in the morning he doesn't leave
he did such an unbelievable job
the contract is respected him everybody
respected him so the wife comes up he's
doing so great Donald he's so amazing
and they give him an honor and this is a
tough group of people that have this
love you know the club members and
they're difficult
they gave him an honor the club came in
under budget faster by two months he did
an unbelievable job and the quality of
the work was ten times what they ever
anticipated so they gave him a medal I
said you know Alex you were to go and do
this for a living you were to be a
builder whether it's houses or clubs or
golf courses renovation or this oh my
father would go crazy at devil levity so
Alex went back to Wall Street where he
was miserable and a year later he quit
and he started doing renovations of
houses and clubs and different things
and he's doing great so you've got to
love what you do
step number one is the most important
part of the process and that is prepare
your mind alright when we get into ruts
okay we get into relationship ruts we
get into workout ruts we get into career
ruts when this happens we let ourselves
Worth and our value depreciate right we
don't feel as confident as good as we
should well step number one is to
prepare yourself to start feeling good
about yourself in order to take action
and to realize that you are not only a
success you are going to be an
incredibly valuable commodity you need
to condition your mind and realize that
you are a valuable asset okay you're not
just John from accounting no you're John
yeah you might work in accounting now
but look out world I am coming but you
need to realize that the job hunting
process and finding a new career it's
not a quick fix alright if it was
everybody be doing it okay it does take
time and the bigger or more drastic of a
change that you're going to make the
longer you're going to need to prepare
for but one thing that is critical is to
keep your mind focus and to keep your
mind in a good space one thing that I
would recommend doing in order to feel
good about yourself something that works
for me and I know it works for a lot of
other people is to volunteer yeah it has
absolutely nothing to do with your new
career but it has to do with you feeling
good about yourself this is also a great
time to up your image at your style your
grooming game alright what happens after
you get a haircut exactly feel great
what happens when you get a new pair of
shoes yes you're like whatever check out
my shoes I feel good right this is a
perfect time to take inventory of what
you have spruce up where you need to but
all in all you're putting together the
best personal package that you possibly
can from mind to shoes one of the
problems in the world is that you have
two choices
almost always you can choose status or
you can choose substance and he says
what happens with a lot of people when
they're figuring out what they should do
with their life you know they listen to
let's say your mom says oh being a
doctor you know that's such a great job
it's so prestigious you'll always make
money but and so people I in fact my den
so I was like 15 years old he wanted to
be an artist he told me but his mom made
him be a dentist because it was a higher
status but he didn't have that real
feeling for it you know even that the
substance wasn't there
so Peter teal the uh you know he's the
co-founder of PayPal and now a
billionaire he says when you have those
choices when you have that fork in the
road really go after the substantive
thing and so as you're figuring out your
general career in your business destiny
don't just go okay everybody now I'm not
saying you shouldn't be a doctor a lot
of people should be doctors we need more
good doctors but don't be a doctor just
because the status is there because you
won't have the highest level of
curiosity that you need to really thrive
in what you ever do and the first part
of this three-step passionate work
framework is becoming a self expert and
understanding yourself because if you
don't know what you're looking for
you're never going to find it and the
thing is that no one's going to do this
for us you know there's no major in
university on passion and purpose and
career I don't know how that's not a
required double major but don't even
don't even get me started on that I mean
you spend more time picking out a dorm
room TV set than you do you know picking
your major in your area of study but the
point is it's on us to figure that out
and we need a framework we need a way to
navigate through this and so the first
step of our compass is finding what our
unique strengths are what are the things
that that we wake up loving to do no
matter what whether pay to or not pay
the things that people thanked us for
and strengths finder 2.0 is a book and
also an online tool highly recommended
for sorting out what it is that you're
naturally good at and then next what's
our what's our framework or our
hierarchy from making decisions you know
is that the people that are do we care
about you know the people our family
health or is it achievement success all
this difference up we have to figure out
what it is to make these decisions so we
know what our soul is made of so that we
don't go selling it to some cause we
don't give a [ __ ] about and then the
next step is our experiences we have all
of us have these experiences we learn
things every day every minute about what
we love what we hate what we're good at
what we're terrible at and if we don't
spend time paying attention that and
assimilating that that learning and
applying it to the rest of our life it's
all for nothing it's like every week
actual every day every week every month
every year I spend some time just
reflecting on what went right what went
wrong and what do I want to repeat what
can I apply more to my life and even
more so than that as you see people
especially today who inspire you who are
doing things where you say oh god what
Jeff is doing I want to be like him why
are you saying that open up a journal
write down what it is about then that
inspires you it's not going to be
everything about their life but you know
whatever it is take notes over time we
have this repository of things that we
can use to apply to our life and have a
more passionate existence and make a
better impact because when we start to
do put these things together we can then
define what it is success actually means
to us and without these different parts
of the compass it's impossible we end up
in the situation we have that you know
scripted life that you know everyone
seemed to be living going up this ladder
to nowhere it's kind of like in Wall
Street to of anyone saw that the kind of
peon employee asked the big Wall Street
bank or CEO said you know what's your
number everyone's got a number what they
make this money they leave it all this
is so simple
more free just smiles and this it's the
sad state of most of the people that
haven't spent time understanding what
actually matters then we keep reaching
for something that doesn't mean anything
to us but we're doing it because
everyone said we're supposed to but once
we have this framework together we can
start to identify that thing that makes
things that make us come alive you know
before this passion could come and hit
you in the face or maybe in your
possible life work you might throw it to
the side because you don't have a way of
identifying it but once you do you can
see something that's congruent with my
strengths my values Who I am as a person
so I'm going to grab a hold of some
going to do something with it and I'm
going to pursue it and try and try to
make an impact with it and you live your
legend and the movement we've built
wouldn't exist if I didn't have this
compass to identify wow this is
something I want to pursue and make a
difference with so if we don't know what
we're looking for we're never going to
find it if you want to know how to
decide if a career opportunity is a good
one there are several things you have to
take into consideration number one does
it make your heart sing the number one
feedback system that you are given at
birth is joy if you're not experiencing
joy as you as you think about doing
something and as you pursue doing it
then it's off course for you you also
want to put your rational mind to work
you want it to some due diligence ask
other people who've gone
down that road before what was it like
what did they have to do what were some
of the cost of that path well were some
of the bay offs and the benefits and
really get a sense of what it would be
like to do that sometimes you can go and
do an internship or you can work for a
friend in their restaurant just to see
if you like it because often the fantasy
doesn't match the reality and the other
thing is to simply trust yourself you
know deep inside what's true for you and
if you'll take a few minutes and go
inside we call it meditation and just
ask and sit with the question and see
what kind of feelings come up does this
feel right so do all the rational
research but then ultimately bring it
back into your heart and decide does
this feel good for me and if it makes
sense up here and it feels good then
step into it just lean into it and see
what happens pursue it no decision is
forever you can always change if it's
not what you want
how should I approach finding a career
that is fulfilling but doesn't
strengthen my ego and secondly and
perhaps the more pressing question for
me is how do I do this while also
becoming comfortable and embracing the
uncertainty that's defining my life
right now good lesson - yes so to what
extent have you become successful in
embracing and accepting at this time of
your life that you don't know yet what
your purpose is to what extent are you
able to say well c-can I become
comfortable with not knowing have you
been able to do that I'm curious where
I've been able to but mostly it's just a
lot of thinking and feeling very
uncomfortable about not knowing yes so
when these thoughts arise they tell you
it's not okay the way you are right now
is not okay realize that these are
thoughts that arise in your mind
conditioned but by the surrounding
culture and so on and you don't
necessarily need to believe in each
thought it comes and tells you it's not
okay not to know what to do life is an
adventure it's not a packaged tour when
you travel you can take a package tour
and everything is already planned
there's no uncertainty and every year go
to huge nice hotel room the more exotic
country but you won't even know it's
exotic because your tailor is the same
as every other hotel room you're totally
sure about everything is planned you
know beforehand where you're going to be
in ten days time exactly that's not an
advance and it's unlikely that you are
going to evolve internally through a
trip like that but if you went into a
true trip into some exotic country
thrown back on your own resources then
you would encounter true adventure but
all in the end you would probably not be
the same person when you come back why
not
because we are constantly faced with
uncertainty and if you're able to accept
that you can actually enjoy the
adventure if you cannot accept it I'm
giving this analogy of a trip because
life is a journey
yes so realize that life is an adventure
and part of the adventure of life is
being in that state that you are in now
if everything were already clear to you
now everything we already mapped out
there would be no evolution of yourself
and maybe I say IV that is part of what
being 26 is all about that is that is
what 26 is you're trying to figure it
out that is yeah that is what the 20s
are for yes and and another very helpful
thing to remember is one of the most
wonderful things it in your period of
life is to make mistakes
yeah because mistakes means you realize
oh that's not that wasn't my purpose yes
and so you're a little bit closer to
your true verbs and then perhaps you
think oh baby that is my father's and
then you after a while you realize no
that's not and it's very helpful to make
mistakes because gradually you begin to
realize what it is that is right for you
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed my quick take on it is
I think there's a lot of pressure people
put on themselves to find the right
career and often way too early
whether it's pressure you put on
yourself or pressure that other people
friends family society is putting on you
and I think the worst thing that you can
do is get yourself locked in
a career and not be able to jump off I
think too many people do it because it's
a smart thing the safe thing to do and
they end up living for the weekends in
the evenings and they hate their jobs
and that ends up being you know they
hate their lives and I don't want that
to be you and I think it takes a lot of
courage to jump off one path to go for
something else especially when you don't
know how it's going to work out but if
you find yourself going to work every
day and hating what you're doing then
you have to change you have to change
what you're up to because otherwise
that's what you're going to do for the
rest of your life and it's only going to
get harder and harder and harder to jump
off to a different career path for me
it's chasing what what makes me come
alive if you have something that you're
curious about go out and try it don't
don't make it some big expensive project
that you just can't afford to do that
requires you to quit your job you know
do something small do something on the
side just test it out whatever big dream
you have whatever curiosity you have
find the smallest way to get started if
you want to learn how to dance salsa for
whatever reason I never imagined being
an owner an investor in a salsa dancing
business but I had an inclination to try
salsa and I liked it and I fell in love
with it and it became a business
opportunity for me I've tried a whole
bunch of other stuff that hasn't worked
out and that's okay too
the important thing is to start small do
little tests see what makes you come
alive see what feels good see what gives
you energy and then continue to find
ways to do that over and over and over
again and the path you know the
staircase will appear with every step
that you take
I made this video because Abdullah asked
me to so there's a topic you'd like me
to cover in the next edition of believe
life leave in the comments I will see we
can do so the question today today is
I'm curious as to how you found your
career or what career advice you give to
other people who are searching for it
leaving the comments below I'm going to
join a discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon
here's a great discovery only the truly
competent individual can be free of
politics in an organization when you're
really good at what you do you can
actually rise above politics
think about it it's the mediocrities at
work you have to play games and every
study shows that although they sometimes
succeed in the short term they
invariably fail when everyone figures
them out
select your work carefully and if you
don't love what you're doing enough to
want to be the best at it get out
flee from the boring or unsatisfying job
as you would from a burning building
working at something that you don't care
about is the very best way to waste your
life remember this life is not a
rehearsal for something else one key to
getting onto the fast track is for you
to work for the right company and the
right boss the right company is one that
respects its people and practices pay
for performance the right company is
dynamic growing open to new ideas and
full of opportunities for people with
ambition and initiative Michael Gerber
the guy that wrote the e-myth you know
talks about why so many businesses young
businesses fail and one of these things
he says is most people are not really
entrepreneurs but they think that's what
they should be they think that's the
sexy thing that's the most attractive
thing that's the best answer and what I
say to you is you've got to separate the
vehicle from the outcome what is it
that's going to truly fulfill you what
is it that's going to give you that
extraordinary life what's going to make
things magnificent on your terms not
somebody else's terms not your father
your mother your background what is that
really separate the vehicles there's
many ways to get to that vehicle what
I'm saying sometimes you got to
reevaluate what's going to really make
you fulfill what is your gift are you an
artist are you the talent can produce
something no one else produces as a
skill or a product or a service or some
impact are you incredibly good at
management you really know how to manage
or lead people are you an extraordinary
entrepreneur that has can take that
gigantic gut load of risk and can create
the vision and
tract the talent that you need in the
managers and leaders you may have all
three abilities but which one really
fulfills you the most is going to be the
critical question because we tend to
want to do them all especially the room
like this because you're all
overachievers right me too
and you say I can do all these yes you
can but what will it do to your quality
of life see again the secrets going to
be this what is an extraordinary life on
your terms today